my name is Walter benezia for months I
was trapped in the evil Dynel ROVs dial
dimension a place where I was duplicated
dozens of times eventually I managed to
escape but now die rob is sending his
army to take me back with the help of my
friends he fight them off and hoped to
ultimately take down mr. rage dinosaur
the more we countdown the weaker he gets
this is top-5
have you guys seen my Batman hoodie
Wow green really is your color where'd
you find the Green Lantern ring anyway I
just took it off the Walter hey you guys
made some changes was gone huh hey
remember that awful Green Lantern movie
with Ryan Reynolds I hated that movie so
much too - it wasn't that bad there are
way worse DC movies DC cinematic history
is spotty at best they've had some
amazing game-changing films over the
years but it seems like for every Wonder
Woman or Dark Knight there's a Superman
for Jonah Hex
last year I counted down the worst
Marvel movies so it's only fair to look
at DC's blunders as well these are the
top 5 worst DC movies number 5 Green
Lantern in 2011 I was excited to see one
of my favorite comic book heroes Green
Lantern brought to the big screen what I
got was a CGI trash fest so bad that I
threw my red ring of anger at the screen
afterwards the movie follows pilot Hal
Jordan who discovers a dying alien who
gives him a ring
this ring is powered by the green light
of will and gives the wearer its powers
Hal must now become a part of the Green
Lantern Corps and help save the universe
one of the main problems with this movie
is it's heavy reliance on CGI which in
and of itself is not a bad thing but the
CGI in this movie was so unforgivable it
was distracting I understand what they
were going for with the suits emitting
and being made of energy but it just
fell so flat burnt bacon is the most apt
description of these suits that I've
heard
[Music]
I know buddy it's painful something
unique about the Green Lantern character
in the comics is his ability to create
constructs of whatever he can imagine
out of the energy of the Ring the movie
Green Lantern also has this ability
increased imaginative constructs like
swords guns and obvious Hot Wheel
sponsorships perhaps the most enraging
thing about this movie is the characters
Hal Jordan is a grade-a jerk from start
to finish with almost no redeeming or
relatable qualities he spends over half
the movie running away from being a
green lantern doubting himself and being
afraid one of the villains Hector is
supposed to have a story that parallels
Hal's
instead he comes off as a whiny
defeatist with daddy issues the other
villain parallax is supposed to be an
ominous and body meant of fear in this
movie though he's an aimless blob
traveling through the universe gobbling
up planets and is stupid enough to be
tricked into being pulled into the Sun
overall it was safe boring and
predictable everything a Green Lantern
movie should not have been number 4
Batman and Robin everyone knows why this
is on here Batman and Robin are
challenged by Mr Freeze the newly
poisoned poison ivy and her personal
thug Bane in a way too soon call back to
the Adam West style Caped Crusader at
this point we had grown past this
version of the character and wanted
something a little more mature we had
gotten the Burton Batman movies and
while maybe too dark for some they
captured what Batman has come to be
known as a tortured soul out on a
never-ending crusade against crime
Batman Robin did a lot to stunt the
growth of superhero movies in fact it
was the death of them for a short while
but without it would we have ever gotten
the Nolan trilogy heck would we have
ever gotten the MCU without superhero
movies bottoming out and audiences
demanding better quality we may still
have been in those dark times so you can
both blame and thank Batman and Robin
for this either way it is an important
film in the history of the current
explosion of comic book movies since all
the negative things about this film have
been said many times over I want to
point out one aspect I actually kind of
liked that being the Alfred scenes I've
said it before now
red is one of my favorite bad family
members and he's definitely the most
important to Bruce's character his
subplot was a good one
when Alicia Silverstone wasn't there in
any case time has been a lot kinder to
Batman and Robin than one would think
it's fun to laugh at now that we have
the security of knowing the character
has been done justice on the big screen
since number three Superman 3 Superman 3
is worse than 4 yeah I said it random
genius computer programmer Gus Gorman is
roped into his scheme by totally not Lex
Luthor rich bad guy Ross Webster - among
other things
recreate kryptonite and take down
Superman however an unknown element in
the compound is replaced with tar and
this version of Kryptonite effects
Superman by turning him into a drunk the
attempts at comedy in this film make me
want to puke director Richard Lester
took over for Richard Donner to finish
up Superman - and the studio stayed with
him for the third installment he
basically turned everything serious from
the first and part of the second film
into an over to our slapstick romp yes
the first two films had comedic and
campy elements in them and they blended
pretty well except for Lester's random
additions to Superman - but for the most
part it's one of the reasons why I love
them they're unapologetically serious
when they need to be and light and fun
when called for Superman 3 is one big
joke making Superman kind of evil was an
interesting idea that's been done well
since but this was horrible no one
should ever see Superman getting drunk
at a bar or about to have sex with not
miss Tessmacher the junkyard fight with
Clark and bad Superman is kind of fun
but it just felt like a big waste of
time in an overly long film also what in
the hell is up with the giant evil
computer at the end there's a legit
disturbing scene when Webster's sister
is forcibly turned into an evil computer
robot where did that come from there's
not a single likeable character in this
whole movie Superman 4 is almost as bad
but at least there are plenty of good
clean weird moments of classic Reeve
Superman Plus gene Hackman's Lex Luthor
is always a positive to see on screen
with this Man of Steel
supergirl the movie opens Ankara in her
home of Argo city right away cars
character and behavior are odd she acts
like a small child like she is seeing
her city for the first time her uncle
lets her play with a power source called
the omegahedron she breaks the barrier
keeping Argo city alive and the orb
flies into outer space
kurama's travelled to earth to retrieve
the powerful omegahedron and save her
home on earth Salina the witch has
little more magical powers than a party
trick until a mysterious orb comes into
her possession with the omegahedron
she's able to cast actual spells and
manipulate those around her but her
powers are incredibly inconsistent
Zelena drugs and then casts an
old-school love spell on Ethan that will
make him fall in love with the first
person he sees when he opens his eyes
when the roofies wear off how do I make
this sound less rapey I can't when the
roofies wear off Ethan somehow makes his
way into town without seeing anyone
until you guessed it he's rescued by
Supergirl and opens his eyes to her
alter ego Linda Lee the most
unforgivable part of the shoehorned
romance is that Kara seems to
reciprocate this total stranger
declaring his love before even knowing
her name the movie spent way too long
focusing on this far-fetched love story
when it was supposed to be a story about
Supergirl we rarely get to see Supergirl
doing heroic stunts rather we get her
falling in love and going to school
that's what women want write a story
about boys fitting in and making friends
although the movie did get a bit
interesting when Selena sent car to the
Phantom Zone wait how does Selena know
about the Phantom Zone
we have to see Kara struggle grow and
learn about herself and her powers now
if only the rest of the movie were like
this squirt
okay maybe not like that
[Music]
and the number one worst CC movie is
Catwoman patience Phillips a timid
graphics designer for a makeup
corporation accidentally stumbles upon
the evil plans of her company their
skincare causes severe reactions if you
discontinue using it but makes your skin
youthful and impervious to damage with
regular application I get the ingenious
evilness of loyal for life customers but
why would you give potential
invincibility to the masses so patience
has obviously seen too much and must be
taken care of by flushing her down the
drains and somehow onto a clearing where
there are cats just chilling to breathe
into her face forever changing her into
an Egyptian god that has possessed women
throughout history this half-baked
exposition is explained by the local cat
lady and convenient expert named Bo
philia powers from her new powers
patience has a sexual awakening and you
found penchant for leather and the
ability to use a whip and other combat
without any prior training side effects
include acting like a literal cat green
straight-up
[Music]
after a quick makeover she gymnastic Li
crashes a diamond heist in progress but
soon realizes the real chest for her
self-confidence is to beat up her boss
I guess we're expected to believe this
face cream is just caked on this lady's
entire body because she withstands a lot
of blows unfortunately for our evil
genius that super self she's been
Hawking isn't fall off the roof proof
everything about this movie is bad
ridiculous names and dialogue
unbelievably tropi characters nauseating
editing and that costume honestly I
could go on about this film for an
entire episode but thankfully there's
already a great one conveniently on this
channel we all agree that Catwoman is
the worst DC movie but is it worse than
Marvel's number one worst movie Howard
the Duck check out a new video on my
personal channel where I addressed that
question since I've been back there are
also plenty of new videos up on there
including Power Rangers unboxings a Star
Wars rebels series finale review the
official gogo Terminator music video the
complete where's Walter Saga and much
more we want to hear what you guys think
what's your least favorite DC movie what
do you want to see us cover next on the
show leave us a comment down below to
keep in touch you can like my Facebook
page or follow along on Twitter and you
can find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash other ruse and you can find me on
Facebook as Iona weed or everywhere else
as awesome Ayana we'll catch you right
back here next week for the best of DC
on a brand new episode of top 5 see you
then
[Music]
[Applause]
you